[Music]
hi
i'm travis gerke um thanks for being
here thanks for having me this is
tremendous i'm i'm excited i don't know
how to put it um so i lead a couple of
data science teams at moffitt cancer
center
in tampa florida you can find me at that
twitter handle it's my name
um and i actually just tweeted out all
the slides
and the code that kind of goes along
with making these slides
although this is not a technical talk
this is just to talk about writing job
descriptions
uh and things which are typically boring
probably uh hr nuances
um i'm sorry if there's any hr people in
here um but but we're going to talk
about that
um so in particular i'm interested in
how we write job descriptions and how
those end up mapping to certain salaries
for data scientists and in particular
for our data scientists i found this
challenging often
and i thought i'd just share some
experiences and hopefully give some good
information for you all
i hope this is a message that most data
science managers
um seek to convey and i hope they
practice it
certainly they all want to hire the most
talented data scientists but importantly
i hope they want to compensate them
accordingly seems pretty simple
but in practice it doesn't always pan
out that way um this is a retweet of a
parody account
so associate deans is a parody account
that that talks about
uh sort of bureaucratic silliness and
mostly academia
um and and here what they're talking
about is soft money positions
so what a soft money position is uh it's
it's a position
where you where an investigator has
brought grant money to an institution
um and they hire someone to work on
their grant with with their grant money
and they feel empowered at least they
feel like they should have full control
over how that grant money is spent so
they should be able to
hire the people they want and pay them
as much as they want because they sort
of they sort of
you know earned that money um but then
hr kind of gets in the way so to speak
right
um so uh here jason is lamenting this
fact
and he's saying oh well i you know i
know i want to hire and i want to pay
them so i'm out but hr is now telling me
that that i have to pay them
less um and and i jumped onto this
thread and i said yes i feel this as
well
i've experienced this myself uh many
times where i want to pay a data
scientist who i know is worth their
weight in gold
some amount of money and then hr might
say oh no that's there's there's another
calculation that has to happen here
and you have to pay them less so we're
left kind of with the question
uh these hr people um are there our
friends are
are they are there enemies um
which whichever the case and again i'm
so sorry there's hr people in here i
promise it gets better
um whatever the case may be
i started to think maybe there's another
way right maybe we can trick them
like maybe if if i write a job
description that describes a person who
does not actually exist
then they can't do a salary benchmark
analysis and they can't establish a
baseline for my person who doesn't exist
and then i can price
point how i want um seems seem pretty
fair uh and maybe other people have had
this idea and thus
unicorns are born right maybe this is
how it happened um we've all seen these
kinds of
postings these data science unicorn
postings out you know and job
boards and whatever um where they ask
for a really really long list of
uh skills and and needs and technical
requirements and things like that
um and so we're going to talk about
those kinds of people
when i thought i would take the strategy
that i'm going to write a unicorn
posting um i thought well i should find
one to use as a template because it's a
little bit
it's kind of a lot i don't i don't know
a whole lot of programming language i
know i know are pretty well i know some
other things but like i don't know what
i'll put in those um so i started
shopping around uh and with some help uh
we identified this one which was live
just last week um
on indeed um and you don't have to read
all that i'll walk you through what this
person's
uh gonna do this is not my posting this
is someone else's posting um
so they're gonna do this personal do
some machine learning
they'll deploy some models in production
so we'll do some machine learning
engineering it looks like
they're going to build applications and
they're going to develop and implement
cloud-based security solutions
cool and then they'll integrate data and
do some decision-making so it sounds
like there's some decision science
tasks that are on this person's plate um
fair enough
so here are the technical requirements
um for for that person
i'll mention something that's at the
bottom that didn't make the cut as they
only had
your zero to one year of experience and
they know all these things um
but but anyway don't don't read all this
stuff but i i did read all these things
and then as i stared at them
um i became more convinced that a
contemporary r
user who is equipped with enough our
packages at their disposal which all of
you have
um and the r studio suite of tools which
makes doing a lot of these things very
easy
um they can do all of these things uh
with with a single language and
a single toolkit um so there's a lot of
languages listed on there
and i don't really think they're all
necessary right i mean they want this
person to do exploratory data analysis
okay tidy verse
they want them to do some visualizations
okay ggplot
um and then they want you know to
wrangle large complex data potentially
so there's all kinds of things out there
data.table
vroom other other resources even dtplier
now um
you know dashboards shiny visualizations
like all this stuff it happens
interfacing with modern database
technologies
um we have packages for that now um deep
learning machine learning all of it in r
so i became convinced right so that our
unicorn is real
and i want to maybe i want to actually
not trick hr but write the correct
uh job posting for the person that i
want i want a unicorn-like person
who knows r and i think i think we
should be able to write a job
description like that
but in order to be able to do so um well
hang on
there's a problem uh we've seen warnings
like this out there on twitter and from
other resources and in particular from
this book which i want to point out is
if you read one book this year read this
one even if you're not seeking a job
it's called building build a career in
data science from emily robinson
jacqueline nolis
i devoured it in like three days um and
they very eloquently
uh kind of map out the challenge here
where they say there are lots of
listings that look like the previous one
that i just described
but it might be a red flag that the
company doesn't know what they actually
want from a data scientist
um and so you might want to sort of
beware um
and yet i just claim that these unicorns
are real and importantly that we should
pay them the right amount
um so back to the exercise how do we do
this
to do this um you notice i had a
co-author on this talk her name is donna
evans
she's a senior compensation consultant
at moffitt um
and to know how the job description
moves from
those words to a quantitative salary
estimate
for the person that you want to hire i
needed to understand the black box
voodoo that happens in the middle
um so she helped me with that and here
it goes so the hiring manager writes a
job description we all knew that was
coming first i think
you actually only have to write a couple
of things in that job description
the first being the primary purpose and
the expected deliverables this is almost
a one-liner
what why does this job exist in this
company right you just got to say that
and then some requirements are on
technical skills prior experience and or
education
and these don't have to be extremely
verbose
with that information hr will then
classify the role they'll give it a
title
in this case we're going to be working
with the data science title data
scientist
and within that domain then they'll
classify whether or not this is going to
be an hourly or a salary roll so exempt
versus non-exempt
the type of contributor are they
technician a professional or a scientist
and within each of those domains
what level are they contributing at so
entry through principle
once they have that classification in
hand they turn to benchmarking data
which is purchased from
compensation survey companies um
and those data resources are a bit
different than what you might be used to
so
like if like me you've sat down and
you've googled what does a data
scientist at company abc make
you'll get some results back it'll
probably be self-reported results from
someone who said i worked at company abc
a couple years ago and i made this
um and that's valid but their problems
with that sort of data self-report bias
it's incomplete other things like that
um so it might not be the best these
compensation survey companies are pretty
different
what they do is they have clients who
purchase the data from them and as part
of that agreement
they they contribute data back so the
organization that has bought the data
then
goes across their organization and they
say here are all the job descriptions
and the job titles that we have
and here's what those people actually
make today um and so then they send
those back to the compensation survey
company and they aggregate it and they
send it back out to all their clients
right
um so importantly these are now salaries
that are that are
real time more or less um from warm
bodies in those positions and that's
important
then hr divisions usually purchase more
than one such survey
so moffett we have many and and we sort
of just
the hr com the the rhr group will take
them and aggravate them together maybe
summarize them
take a median and an interquartile range
and then according to
any individual organization's
compensation philosophy that's how you
come at the number
um so the compensation philosophy could
vary a little bit um for example in the
startup world
um where things like bonus incentives
stock options all that stuff is more
common
the base seller might kind of like dip a
little bit lower because you have all
those other things and of course there
are companies on the other end of that
spectrum but that's sort of where that's
how this happens more or less
so i iterated with donna a couple times
to
understand how i could write a job
description that mapped
to roles that appear in those
compensation surveys
so for title uh the data scientist title
was obvious we started there
and that that ended up being a pretty
good decision and then within these
surveys um they tend to have five levels
for data scientists so one
being entry level and then five being a
principal data scientist kind of at the
senior end of these things
so here we'll walk through them here's a
data scientist one
generically they're going to do the
thing that all data scientists do right
summarize and analyze
potentially complex and large data to
guide business insights that's just what
we
probably most of you do um and then
they'll do some other stuff that we
would expect
merge and tidy data do some
visualizations organize databases maybe
do some analysis
they'll produce reports uh and and
they'll make it accessible to the end
users
i have a bullet in there which is where
i just wrote kind of our stack
experience just off the top of my head
um and this is incomplete even for me um
but
i importantly put a wild card here for
you if you're writing job descriptions
um you can put in whatever r stuff that
you would like your person to
to know in there and it will not change
the leveling of these things
um to my knowledge i checked that with
don and that seems to be true
the last two are actually important
bullet points when it comes to salary
benchmarking
um may require an advanced degree so may
is hr
code speak for not required um so we
don't actually need that in this role
um and zero to two years of related
experience preferred
um also preferred being code speak for
not required um so this is
very much aligning with an entry level
position and that's good right
um and so the notes are things that do
not appear actually in in the job
posting
but it's important for you to know to
think about how this data scientist will
operate
um this one will report to manager and
have their work closely managed because
they're entry level
um and their projects often have limited
complexities they kind of learn the
nuance of the role
i'll move to two and you'll see that
nothing changes except that last bullet
point so i left the purpose
and the r stack all that stuff the same
and now we just have two to four years
of related experience
typically required so they need some
kind of experience but here's where you
can start to mix and match experience
with advanced degrees
so if someone has an advanced degree in
some quantitative science or computer
science or whatever it may be
you can swap that out for the two to
four years of related experience and
you'll get a
data scientist too and now they're
requiring occasional direction so you
don't need someone looking over their
shoulder all the time
and they're getting some exposure to
complex tasks of the job
three now we have four to seven years of
experience or an appropriate mix of that
and
an advanced degree right so they have an
advanced agreement this counts as
two to five years of experience
depending what sort of degree we're
talking about
and now um they require minimal
direction so more autonomy as we move
through these stages
more complex challenges here's a four
this work is primary and primarily
independent from this contributor
and they often lead teams for complex
problems um
seven plus user-related experience again
maybe appropriate mix with an advanced
degree
and lastly we have the principal data
scientist data scientist five
who is fully autonomous and they're
leading their teams to
tackle the most challenging problems
encountered by the data science unit
so that's it that's one through five
these are the job descriptions and they
map to
titles and levels which appear in the
compensation surveys
so here's maybe what you're hoping to
see um here's what those people actually
make
across the country so this is aggregated
survey data
from many surveys that moffitt has
purchased so i'm not showing you any one
survey um for proprietary data reasons
um and i'm and i've only got three um
number summaries here so just a median
an interquartile range that i'm
presenting stratified by region
um uh so here um we see the the dark
blue is across the whole united states
um for data scientists one through five
and we see regional trends that we might
expect because of cost of living
so the light blue is the south uh
southeast u.s
um then we have orange and yellow as the
the west
uh the west coast and the northeast
higher cost living
that make a bit more data scientist one
tends to be in the 60 000 a year range
all the way up through the five which
those tend to appear north of 150 000 a
year
if that's not granular enough there's
also this map which you go to the slides
you can use it's interactive so um you
can kind of mouse over and see what
these people
would make if you are interested in a
census track or a particular
metropolitan area
if you either work there or job hunting
or hiring in those areas this could be
useful for you so as an arbitrary
example here's nashville
data scientist 1 and the 55 per year
range data scientist 5 and the 130
per year we can jog over here to where
we are now the bay area you all are well
you're either money bags or you have a
high cost of living maybe it's both
um so you got you've got 87 000 a year
at the one and then and then uh north of
200 a year for for the principal data
scientist right
so hopefully these things are useful
what did i learn from going through this
process
um i didn't know anything about hr when
i went through this but
i was experiencing pain experiencing
pain of having to interact with hr
and not knowing how they work to be able
to communicate with them well to hire
the people that i want and pay them like
what they're worth right um so your own
your own institution do that hr
is actually your friend they're helpful
um this it was so enlightening for me
they're really trying to do their best
um they often don't understand data
science roles because they're not data
scientists for the most part um
so talk to them that will help um
primary this is
something important that i that i took
home from this um primary drivers of
salary estimates
are experience this is like years of
experience and autonomy of the role
um and it's not like the number of
languages that you know
um i think there's a temptation among
all of us certainly it's true for me i'm
always like oh if i just knew that one
more language or that one like if i took
this boot camp or whatever
my career trajectory would look
different um i don't think that's
necessarily true
um particularly for our users you know a
lot and you can deliver a lot of value
to
any institution that you choose to join
feel empowered to apply for those roles
and you
should get them because i think you're
all awesome
so you don't need like language x you
just probably need r at least in my
opinion in my
um so and these drivers unfortunately i
don't know that they're totally correct
right um for data science in particular
autonomy fair enough um but experience
it's hard to have 10 plus years
experience in a technology which isn't
10 or more
years old um like shiny is a semi
arbitrary example right um i don't
really know how to navigate that and
there's not really good solutions in the
hr domain but i think at least they're
aware of it
um so at you know individual
organizations you can talk to them about
that sort of thing
these salary surveys are not yet
capturing uh specific data science roles
um so again in the build a data science
career book they do a very great job of
spelling out
all the data science subdomains just
like machine learning engineer
a decision scientist all kinds of
business intelligence analysts all this
stuff there's all these words
and they do a good job of spelling that
out because that hasn't been
standardized for
a long period of time many companies
aren't hiring into those titles and so
they're not reporting out data on those
so we do not yet
have data on how much each of those sub
niche roles sort of make but that will
change in the coming years
i'm not arguing for or against the
current process i'm just telling you
what it is
i'm kind of powerless against the
machine just like so many of us are
right i mean
there indeed are there are federal laws
that are in play here so i mean you you
really can't
um diverge too much from from what the
standards actually are
um but at least by understanding the
process i mean you may be empowered to
understand
if you're a job seeker where you land in
the data science one through five
track um and if you're a manager um it
might also empower you to help know how
you want to write the job description to
get the unicorn that you actually need
i feel to thank here um so don evans of
course my uh compensation consultant and
hr guru she was immensely helpful
um jordan creed many of you probably
already saw her because she was giving
out the the unicorn heck stickers which
she also made
she's a great data scientist and
apparently also a future pr
um representative um garrick and booty
carricaden bowie i've seen him thanked
in at least half the talks here um
and he's similar here because he makes
so many good tools that everybody uses
um because i benefit from working with
him i was able to get advanced access to
share engine extra package
which made a lot of the fanciness that
you saw on these slides happen if you're
interested in such
things this g g giraffe i think is how
it's called package is what made that
interactive
map happen um within the slides outside
the context of plotly also if you're
interested in how those things work
that's a pretty great package thanks to
the tampa user group
they did a quick feedback on this i gave
a little preview of this talk a few
weeks ago
and they gave some great feedback and
again emily and jacqueline for that for
that book
um there's a link please do check it out
if you're interested in any of these
sorts of topics you'll you'll find that
book fascinating
um they're going to the resources if you
find me on twitter thank you again it's
so awesome to be here
[Applause]
thank you so much travis um we have a
few questions that are queued up for you
the first one is there are still many
job descriptions that specify
python only and sometimes they they even
say
r is insufficient yeah how should our
community approach the situation
i mean so it's that can be valid right i
mean if if an institution has a large
technology stack that's built around
python there's probably not much of a
way to get around it
um you can go in there and do a lot of
the same things with r but if it's
in particular if it's a large
organization you're not gonna be able to
knock down the python vertical and like
put up r in its place as as a new
employee um i disagree strongly with the
r is insufficient um
i don't know you probably don't want to
work at that place let's
let's just say it all right fair enough
uh next question was actually about how
the the map was built which you answered
on your last slide oh great
uh next one is how can data scientists
develop
their autonomy what should we read
learn and do
i suppose demonstrating that you have
independent packages you know i mean
everybody looks for the portfolio every
hiring manager says oh do you have a
github
i mean most these days do right what's
your github portfolio look like
i know and i also appreciate the the
fact that it's a lot to ask people on
their free time to like build up their
own projects because they're often
currently working with a company where
things are protected and they can't
share them openly
i don't know what a good solution for
that is a lot of people are talking
about that but i mean that probably is
the best way honestly someone who looks
at cvs and resumes
um you know i can usually get a good
sense of how autonomous thereby looking
at their repository uh
set of repositories right right
one more question uh what are the
federal regulations that hamstring hr
into these processes that you you
criticized
um so what is it the fair standards and
labor act are there any hp yeah i'm
seeing nodding heads i know jeff leake
alluded to this yesterday in his talk in
the morning unfortunately i wasn't but i
heard it was awesome
um so he speaks the same things whereby
he is training
people who don't have advanced degrees
to do data science and he wants to hire
them
into kind of advanced data science roles
but often
that particular law says that those
people cannot be salaried because they
they fall in between a couple of
different categories so jeff is really
kind of a go-to on that
but but that is one of the nuances that
makes this really hard
that makes sense do salaries correlate
with the number of hex stickers on my
laptop
um i can i can give donna some numbers
and then i can report back
um i'll fix i'll fix the map or do a
pull request if anybody wants to do that
can we do it that way um
a lot of jobs are requiring data
scientist skills but calling it a data
analyst
position how do you differ the two yeah
so i mean you're going to have to try to
read between the lines and those job
descriptions
data analyst is a different thing than a
data scientist um i think
at least in the build a data science
career book they specify analysts to be
a bit
tier below the data scientist they're
not aggregating as much data
they're typically closely managed
managed and things like that but there
are other organizations
that for historical reasons have a data
analyst role which performs all the
tasks of a full-blown data scientist and
when they benchmark the salaries of the
data analyst
against these survey companies they'll
actually use the data scientist title
even though that's not what they're
being called in their company so it's
tricky just just read the description
and maybe you know if you go on the
interview try to try to tease out what
it is they're actually having to do
i'm going to read off one more question
ben walking if you don't mind
starting to set up that would be great
um so public universities are often
they often have rigid capped salary
scales our unicorns are golden
our unicorns are golden flavors
golden hooved data scientists who value
working in academia
tips for those job ads oh i mean
academia's tricky
um there there's another layer of
federal requirements around those things
that are related to you know
federal grant money
if if you spelled out in a budget you're
going to pay a data analyst or something
like that
x amount of dollars you're kind of bound
within the context of that grant to pay
them that
although many faculty or investigators
will have additional kinds of like
streams of money that they may have
access to so um feel empowered to seek
the salary that you know you're worth
that's my parting words
travis thank you so much